[Music]
[Music]
we're on the set
the musical episode is happening how are
you
how are you feeling i feel like i've won
a competition yeah
a singing and dancing competition i was
like please can i
one day sing and dance in something
that's really great i'm having a time in
my life yeah i cannot wait for people to
see this episode
i mean what i've seen so far it is so
epic
and i know you guys recorded all your
own vocals kind of walk us through the
process
of what has gone into this episode well
it's been a long time in the planning
actually because yeah
it's been muted around since we've done
like we've done a lot of music in the
show we did some dancing in the show
last season then people like are you
ever going to do a musical episode
we always wanted to find a way to do it
where it wasn't just oh we're doing a
musical episode there needed to be a
reason
for the music and the dancing to happen
it's fun it's really fun uh a little bit
terrifying because it's you know
it's it's professional dancers and big
cameras and cameras they use in the nfl
and
and a lot of uh you know i'm just it's
beautifully overwhelming
yeah and such a big if not our biggest
episode yet
so fun i know i'm surrounded by
professional dancers
i know it's like the closest i'm gonna
have to a beyonce moment so i want to
make sure to get those
steps in grain yeah so that i don't even
have to think about it and i could like
you know give the camera a little sass
and a little ariana grande
hair whip pony i mean this ponytail is
so cute yeah yeah
kaylee our hair sensei was like you
gotta go ariana grande you have to
ain't no sound but the sound is feet
machine gun's ready to go
how has the dancing and the singing been
for you
[Laughter]
great yeah moving on yeah
no no no have you been harder it's been
totally hard for me
it's really really hard this was an
amazing dance i was going to say
i saw the twirl out there you twirled
straight into because i did a good twirl
we did a good tour
it's been fun yeah yeah it's been
challenging and fun
talk about the vocals you sing in this
episode right
i kind of lip-sync we sing all together
yeah on this one on this one
yeah yeah was that scarier for you i
mean this one's an old pro
uh well i will say it wasn't that scary
because they
uh i don't see my own song so i'm just
kind of lip singing
so it's it's easier you know i'm a
little a little uh
scared of singing i'm terrified of it
actually
[Music]
where are lucifer and god in this point
of time are they getting along do they
have issues they are they have
huge issues with huge unresolved issues
um well lucifer certainly does with dad
and dad seems to be
um pretending that nothing you know
nothing's ever been wrong and whatever
which
of course wins lucifer up and he spends
most of his time on his dad just to keep
away from him
and then he has a sort of revelatory
moment in this episode where he's like
maybe for the sake of other things in my
life i should try getting along with my
dad
are we gonna get that duet the god and
the lucifer
singing moment uh you might do how does
having
god sort of shake things up in general
oh my gosh well his presence has been
looming for five years yeah i mean
he has been such an instrumental force
of nature on our show
and fans every year ask is god coming is
god coming is god coming because lucifer
has
all these daddy issues yeah so even
though we've never met him
you definitely feel like his presence is
is there and so you finally meet the guy
who is making the devil insecure
for the first time ever yeah so um so
what's so beautiful about his intro is
that it's a very relatable one
so not no one can relate to being the
devil no one can relate to
you know having wings yeah but everyone
can relate to having that one person
you could be a total boss you could be
you know oprah beyonce and there's that
one person that you just you want their
acceptance
yeah and for lucifer's god are you ready
hey are you ready for this
are you hanging on the edge of your seat
do you have scenes with god
not yet so god is finally introduced and
he's introduced as a father
when the brothers are fighting loose
foreign
you know i like it when yeah i don't
like it when you fight so that's really
that's why god gets involved in the
first place i don't know i think he just
yeah he's a dad
he's got to come look at his kids yeah
so what's really fun about their first
time it's the episode where god for the
first time
becomes human so it's really fun because
i'm in a scene where he experiences
having to pee for the first time
having a brain freeze from a slurpee for
the first time
and so the first time i see him he's
like this is my dad i'm like oh my god
and he's like thank you for your support
and i'm like huh but it's really fun to
see god
because he's been so far removed from
being human he's so divine and so
evolved
that when he goes into human form again
he's like what is this full-bladder
situation
what is this brain-free situation and
what is this not being able to hear
everyone's thoughts
so it's fun it makes them very relatable
does ella know that it's
god because we've talked a little bit
about her faith and how she doesn't
really know that lucifer
is lucifer girl for as smart as
ella is she clueless she's okay she
clueless i mean she still thinks that
lucifer is just an unemployed actor
who like clearly never gets a job so
we're this far in and she still doesn't
know
so does it know she's just like he just
needs a hug yeah you know what i mean
still
and um he's almost like an older brother
she appreciates his puns
um and she has no idea
oh my god i think i even added something
in where
you know when dennis and when she's like
this is my dad i'm like oh adopted
you know what i mean like that's how she
is she's just so
yeah that's so ella by the way
how many songs do we get i think there's
like eight numbers yeah
well yeah it's it's a lot and it's a lot
to shoot on the same schedule that we
shoot anyway do you feel like there's a
theme to all the songs like are they all
sort of
connected we had there was like certain
songs that came up
when we knew what the situation was and
for example the song we're doing today
is like we were desperate to get this
song and get get it cleared and be able
to use it because it's so perfect
um and we did that's the main thing like
we we started this going on
we these are the songs we want to do and
we probably won't get this and we
probably won't get that one
so we'll have a backup we've got all the
songs we wanted i mean from what i've
heard i only
with lyric changes as well weird changes
occasionally
like what oh i can't no
no you won't tell us any in the first
song that lives for sings he drops
a very important lyric from the original
song in order for this song to be
personal for him
what's so great about this musical
episode is that every song is different
yeah some songs are like beyonce playing
with her hair
you know and you get like sex hair going
some are
almost acapella sounding um trixie sings
this beautiful
carol trixie sings this beautiful
beautiful
um almost like thank you this like
acapella sounding song that is just so
tender it breaks your heart
uh tom i think does his best thing he's
ever done wow
he's so nervous about it he crushes it
um he has a duet you know with dennis
i have like a sing-off kind of battle
with with maze
and it's just each song is so
different um you know uh db's uh
linda and amanda dale's song is very
whimsical almost like marvelous mrs
maisel in the park
so what's so beautiful about the show is
that each song is so different
and yet moves the story forward and you
get to see our characters
in a way that you've never seen you said
it moves it forward do you think it's a
pivotal
episode i do i do i mean there's decker
star moments
there's realization moments there's it's
it's really good you guys it's it's
funny because you think musical episode
and you think
light and playful yeah but at the table
read
we're in it we're behind the curtain and
at the table read
we stopped and then it was silent
when we ended and it was
really emotional so it's one of those
things that i think
singing is such a vulnerable thing to do
yeah so you're seeing these characters
almost subconscious you're seeing them
raw
you're seeing them without their mask
yeah which i think we've never really
done on a show everyone kind of
i mean ella's pretty transparent but
you're seeing her most vulnerable thing
in her achilles
heel which is bad boys so what's so
great about this episode is that
every musical number shows someone's
really vulnerable side
like even chloe and and lucifer
they haven't danced together since the
prom episode fans are gonna go nuts like
for their decker star moment to see
lauren spin into tom and and and and
have this i mean we
even that i think that's what they
really want to do but you know when you
really like a guy you're like
hey so yeah that'd be cool if you come
over but whatever no big deal
you know what i mean no one really is so
transparent so this episode shows us at
our most
raw vulnerable and we were freaking out
okay we were going into the studio
and everyone's shaking and there's a
good reason to break into song
it's because god's going a little schizo
so
and he's kind of playing puppet master
he is he
is he's playing puppet master and he's
getting
he's getting old so stuff's getting a
little janky when i first talked to you
you mentioned
that the love the romance for ella gets
a little complicated
this season yes where is she at right
now
is there a love interest there is a love
interest
and this is probably one of if not
ella's darkest moments
and our producer when he he wrote the
episode um chris rafferty was a really
talented writer
he watched the show and he's like we've
never gone this dark on the show i'm
like wait a second you're telling me
that one of the darkest moments of
five years of the show is ella how do
you think fans are going to feel when
they watch this episode
i hope that they love it yeah and i
would say the people that love musical
theater
and musicals are going to absolutely
adore it yeah
you know it's been i mean it's it's nice
because there are lots of fun numbers in
this
in it but there's also a couple of
really heartfelt numbers that are like
proper teenagers like emotional moments
in what way
well uh in the state that our characters
are in
you know when the song comes up and and
then what the words of the song mean to
that character
um we try to find you know some
connection
rather than just being random songs can
i brag about you for a second without
giving anything away
go on then
tom's in a difficult place lucifer is in
a difficult place and tom
goes into song and he played it for me
yesterday the day before and i was in my
trailer just
you know crying at how beautiful
the recording is and knowing the moment
within the story
and i just brought tears to my eyes i
mean it's absolutely touching
and gorgeous um saying so well with the
correct kind of you know
you can feel what he's feeling through
your singing and it's it's gorgeous
that's beautiful how do you feel hearing
that oh you know
no i'm i i'm not gonna lie i'm super
proud of
this whole episode actually and the way
everything's turned out but
this particular song is something that
i've wanted to do on the show
for a while and we needed to find the
right moment and this is totally the
right moment and
i'm just delighted with how it turned
out do you feel like because of the
songs that
we see a more vulnerable side to the
characters in a way
i think i mean i would say that
definitely with lucifer for sure
you know because music is a way into
people's soul a little bit
yep and music is you know in lucifer's
soul and you know that's why i love that
episode with father frank in season one
because it's like these two
holes apart characters and they bond
over music yeah and it's an unspoken
language and i think
yeah it does it taps into parts of lisa
that maybe just the spoken word doesn't
yeah you mentioned your favorite part of
the episode is the opening what is your
favorite part of the episode
well actually i don't love singing and
dancing but we just want something today
that ended up being
oh no oh i know the moment i think
we shot something today that ended up
being very spontaneous but yet also
very fun and ridiculous and silly but
the thing
i think people might like they might
they may hate it
but if they like it i think it's
something that you never imagined chloe
doing
so i think you know anyone who likes the
decker star
situation are gonna have a laugh because
you know chloe just really needs
i've got a feeling it might be a gift
moment this